네 안녕하세요 빌사남 제가 오늘은
2024년 빌딩 투자 키워드를 가지고
좀 오늘 촬영해 보려고 하는데
키워드는 총 다섯 가지를 준비했습니다
그래서 첫 번째는 금리 인하 그리고
두 번째는 거래량은 언제 회복될 건지
그리고 세 번째는 부실 징후 기업
그리고네 번째는 투자 지역은 상급
지로 그다음에 마지막은 불안정한 임대
시장 이렇게 총 다섯 가지를
정했습니다 어 우선 첫 번째부터 좀
말씀드리면 금리 인하가 일단은 내년에
된다는 얘기들이 많잖아요 그래서 얼마
전에 그 제롬 파울도 내년에 한 세
차례 정도 나할 계획이다 뭐 이런
계획도 좀 발표가 돼서 아마 우리나라
금리도 좀 따라서 뭐 내년에 좀
인하가 되지 않을까 뭐 요렇게 좀
예상을 하고 있습니다 작년말 올해
초만 해도 금리가 어느 정도 올라갈지
감이 안
잡혔거나 해도 뭐 제롬 파울이 뭐
금리를 6% 이상 올릴거다 뭐 이런
여론도 있었는데 어느 정도 좀 이제
고지가 보이긴 해 가지고 내년에
어찌됐든 금리 인하가 좀 이루어질
것으로 좀 보여지고 그리고 두 번째
키워드가 거래량이 언제 회복될 건지
제가 뭐 예상하기로는 어찌됐든
상반기는 거래량이 그렇게 좀 많이
상승할 것 같진 않아요 상반기를 좀
지난 하반기부터 조금 거래량이
상승하지 않을까 빠르면 2분기 아니면
3분기부터 거래량이 조금 회복되지
않을까 이렇게 좀 조심스럽게 예상을
합니다 그리고 세 번째로는 부실 징후
기업이라고 했는데 전에 제가 영상에
좀 회계사 님이랑 업데이트한 영상이
있어요 여기 제가 뛰어 들릴 건데 그
영상을 보시면 부실 징후 기업에
해당되는 기업들이 꽤 생길 거거든요
금리가 본격적으로 오은게 작년
하반기부터 올랐습니다 그래서 작년부터
아마 이제 임대료보다 이자가 더 높게
책정이 돼서 적자나는 기업들이 좀
생겼을 것 같거든요 그래서 작년이랑
올해까지 만약에 적자가 나면 은행에서
이제 대출 일부를 좀 갚으라고 하거나
아니면은 연장을 할 때 금리가 좀
올라갈 수도 있습니다 그래서 그런
기업들의 매물이 내년에 많이 나오지
않을까 예상을 좀 해보고요 그리네
번째로는 지금 아무래도 빌딩 시장이
좋지 않기 때문에 매도인 분이 협상이
그래도 잘 돼요 금액 내고야 된다라는
계약 조건을 좀 유리하게 할 수 있기
때문에 지금 만약에 빌딩 투자
하신다고 하면은 무조건 좋은 지역 그
상급지 투자를 좀 권합니다
2021년 해도 지금 그때는 빌딩
시장이 너무 호황이었던 몰사 되게
오르는 시장이었고 지금 같은 시기에는
확실한 거만 좀 투자하는 거를 좀
권하고 싶습니다 그래서 확실한 거라
하면 좀 잘 팔리는 지역 그리고
가격이 계속 오르는 지역 어 이런
지역을 투자하는게 좀 중요하다라고
생각하고요 그리고 마지막으로 임대
시장이 좀 많이 안 좋아졌어요
기존에는 그래도 임대는 잘 맞춰지기
했는데 요즘 같은 때에는 임금도 많이
오르고 기업들이 이렇게 투자 유치가
좀 잘 안 돼요 회사 이전이라는 뭐
그런게 좀 뜸해졌고 그리고 창업하는
그런 사람들도 좀 많이 줄었어요
그래서 좀 불안정한 임대 시장이기
때문에 2024년에 투자할 때는
아무래도 임대를 어떻게 마칠지 좀
중점적으로 고민해 보시면 좋을 것
같습니다 2024년 어 빌딩 시장 좀
키워드를 좀 정리해 보자면 첫 번째로
금리 인하 어 내년에 어찌됐든 금리
인하가 될 것으로 좀 조심스럽게
예상을 하고 거래량 회복은 제가 그냥
예상컨데 빠르면 2분기 아니면
3분기부터 는 거래량이 조금 회복될
것으로네 예상이 됩니다 그리고 세
번째로 부실징후 기업 매물들이
2024년에 좀 많이 나올 것으로 좀
예상이 되고요 그리고 투자 지역은
무조건 확실한 지역에 투자하는 거를
좀 검하고 싶습니다 그리고
마지막으로는 지금 불안정한 임대
시장이기 때문에 좀 확실하게 임대
수익이 나올 만한 임대 수요가 충분히
있을 만한 그런 지역에 투자하는 거를
기억하셨다가 어 2024년에 빌딩
투자하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘
영상 여기까지 하고요 어 지금 벌써
연말이네요네 연말이고 진짜 1년이 좀
빨리 지나가는데 어 여러분들도 연말
마무리 잘 하시고 내년에 어 좀
새로운 새해를 맞이하셨으면 좋겠습니다
오늘 영상 여기까지 하겠습니다
감사합니다